i'm so excited to speak with you guys
and i have been listening to your music
for days on end and i am such a fan so
your music is beautiful wow thank you so
much it's it's the ultimate compliment
and uh definitely
having rose's voice
and their makes it timeless
when you guys met
is it true that you were
almost sort of
torn apart a little bit but there's
something that
happened that kept you
in the loop please tell me about that
so when we first met we were actually on
tour together and the last night of the
tour is when we finally got to talk
and so i'm kind of throwing some lines
out there saying maybe we could get
together and write sometime
um
and she just smiled and
somebody came and got me and said okay
we need you to go sign some tour posters
i left
and came back and i'm looking for
and her bus was gone and i thought man
i missed that chance
and uh
walked on the bus
and as we had talked about music and
books
um
there was a book on my bus
that she left for me and she wrote a
little note with her number and said
maybe we could get together and write or
something
that's exactly what it said
i love that
i love this so much because it's so
cinematic
i will say i tried to call her
immediately and
i
do know from that moment on from that
night
to
to now we've been together there was no
doubt in my mind
i heard people say
thought it was kind of bs that when you
meet the one
you know it's the one there's no there's
no other and that was it i
i was sold i was in
um
forever oh god
and
hearing you speak about
rose rod um
you guys have two beautiful boys
um writer and scout
but it wasn't
the easiest journey to get there
you guys were trying to have children
and you went on a journey together
yeah so i my mother passed away when i
was very young and she had breast cancer
and i ended up being an only child
raised by my father so i just had this
dream of having a big family and when i
married rodney i became a bonus mom to
his son eli
and i just thought the next right thing
to do was that we were going to expand
our family and have a bunch of kids
but it did not work out you know the way
that i planned it and we ended up
struggling with infertility for about
five years
and i'm kind of a researcher so i just
started like looking everywhere i could
for a solution
and i found
a place in barbados actually and you got
to go on like a vacation while doing ivf
so it gives the best of both worlds
and i
just one night told rodney
this is what i want to do i read this
blog and this sounds amazing i have no
idea but i feel in my gut you know this
is the right thing
and he trusted me
and we did it and it worked
it did it worked the second time and we
got ryder the sunrider
congratulations
and then
how did scout come about
skeletons
he just happened it was uh it was
amazing and uh man
they are they're perfect little boys
we're so blessed they're crazy they're
insane crazy but they're awesome i i
really related to rose because after i
had my girls i stopped acting for a long
time and
i started trying to do other things but
i just didn't want to be away from them
and i'm sure
i didn't realize it at the time but i
really kind of lost myself in
my fears concerns wanting to just put
everything in as a mom
and
rod
encouraged you is this true
yeah so what it was a mate so when
she was pregnant rose would say okay i'm
not gonna stop writing songs i have to
work i'm not just gonna be a mom it's
what she would say
and
then when those babies came
seeing her
be a mom
i'm sorry
it was beautiful
and i had to make her i had to make her
go
start writing songs
and um
it was the beautiful most beautiful
thing ever seeing her learn about being
a mom by being a mom she had nothing to
go on
well i didn't expect that but um
and now you have this album rod and rose
and it's your first album together
now you have a single card
put me back together
and for valentine's day we made a little
valentine's day present for you that you
and the kids can do
we made you guys a little atkins family
puzzle because i'm up at like i love it
i'm up for all hours
and i can't thank you enough for coming
on the show and telling us your love
story and
just thank you rodney atkins and rose
falcon your new ep
rod and rose was released on january
28th so be sure to check it out thank
you guys so much
oh thank you for having us thank you
my best to your family we'll be right
back
[Music]
you